In my animal misconceptions video I casually
mentioned that daddy long legs aren’t spiders
and received a ton of comments asking for
clarification or suggesting that it’s not
that simple, so I feel the need to clear things
up a bit, but first, a disclaimer:
If images of spiders make you uncomfortable,
1) you shouldn’t have clicked on this video
and 2) you should stop watching, right, about
now.
Cutest, spider ever.
Right?
When editing the video, I decided to cut out
a daddy-longleg discussion, and now you’ll
see why.
To answer the question ‘are daddy longlegs
spiders?’ we first need to know, what are
spiders?
And for that we need the biological classification
system you should have learned in high school.
Spiders are in the animal kingdom – which
is a pretty broad class of life and not helpful
in narrowing things down.
The phylum that concerns us are the arthropods
which are a subset of animals with external
skeletons, segmented bodies, and jointed limbs.
The arthropods with exactly eight legs and
two body segments are in a class called arachnids
– where the name arachnophobia comes from
– and while often used to mean fear of spiders,
there are plenty of arachnids that are not
spiders, such as scorpions and mites.
The true spiders, are a subset of Arachnids
in the order Araneae.
What defines these as spider are their fangs
and the poison glands within them, their numerous
eyes and their spinnerets that allow them
to make webs.
Now that we have a spider checklist on to
the second problem: the name ‘daddy longlegs’
means different things in different places.
In Australia this cellar spider is called
a daddy longlegs – which as an eight-legged,
multi-eyed, web-spinning member of Araniee
makes it an official spider.
It also produces venom, but then so does everything
in that bloody country.
Where I grew up this is a daddy longlegs (sometimes
called a harvestman).
They have just two, soulless eyes, can’t
web sling and lack fangs and poison glands
and so fail the spider checklist and are in
a different order called Opiliones.
It was these I had it mind while making the
video.
To make things more complicated, in my adoptive
UK the british call this Crane Fly daddy long
legs.
Unlike the closely related Opiliones and Araniee
the Crane Fly isn’t an arachnid but an insect,
the class of arthropods with six legs and
three body segments.
And, as if the name wasn’t ambiguous enough
at this point, there is also a plant called
daddy long legs.
For taxonomical completeness the plant is
over here a different kingdom.
But, because of the way life works even this
plant is distantly related to those other
daddy longlegs because plants and animals
are both eukaryotes which means that their
cells have complex structures, most notably
a nucleus.
So, to fully the first question: there are
four daddy long legs, three animals, two arachnids,
but only one spider among them.